[Music]
do you guys ever read the dimensions of
the things that you order when you are
under the influence of something what
that's a very recently sober layer
because it's very specific to the story
I've never been under the influence of
anything ever I you drink wine you just
took a shot Gina I don't know you ever
told you to buy Facebook ad yes yes well
so yes I've done all of it yeah oh I
tried to online shop to fo avoid in my
heart mm-hmm you literally just
downloaded an app that you saw an
instant I just did yeah it was actually
from tick-tock and now it's trying to
make me pay for [ __ ] and I'm like where
are you guys a buzz huh you were gonna
say something you're like oh and then I
got excited I'm very careful that doing
doing that while you're drunk is like
trying to do homework while you're drunk
I would never look at the dimensions
automate something right so you're just
like oh I need this the price looks
about right let's order it yeah I do
that often I'll just be like I beat it
into submission to make it fit well if
I'm by I actually was buying furniture
the other night I'll go straight Captain
Jack Sparrow and that [ __ ] on my cell
you fill up that
you're literally just grabbing my life
right now I'm buying the for the home
whoa dude I heard you guys have too much
furniture yeah we do we're trying to get
rid of our old [ __ ] so we can make new
for the music so you gotta get you I'll
get your dimensions down she say she
needs a new fur early twenties I was
saying that you were complaining that
your house is too small not bragging my
brain you just try to be relatable so
small but you have an East and a West
Wing too
my Tesla around upstairs is now only
referred to as the North Way we should
start calling our north wing she only
refers our bedrooms it's chamber Siri
telling us that go to your chambers and
shut the door crying he's like my mom
told me last night to go to my chambers
and the teachers like she said you go to
your what I got lost on the way there
you know it's like she was talking
strangely every time he refers to the
hall and he does like do it doing a
British accent so would it be surprised
also he's acting all brand new just cuz
he has a big-ass house now just don't
let him get a pet owl or Falcon or
Nathan I know you do so I'm saying
you're boogy boogy well he goes pissing
in your molt as well
yes okay anyway so the reason I brought
up ordering things all under the
influence is because is this Alabama
woman she she tweeted out something
pretty funny she tweeted out Amazon [ __ ]
you cuz you know damn well hey you know
damn well it's a miniature [ __ ] how
much was it it was like 2 bucks
she was high as [ __ ] and that usually
she like she likes to order things on
how about Alibaba she like would was
cheap and like you know this cheap-ass
bench could have been 2 bucks I don't
know that's what she was in that state
of mind where she thought it made sense
but no once they came in she's like I'm
[ __ ] cute I love that sitting picture
she said I ordered a lot of shake
because I just moved into my crib and
then she was that's it shower curtain is
can you imagine expecting this package
though and you get to the door and the
delivery is like hey here's your [ __ ]
that's not a good business for a house
anyway ok picture that a three roll
quarters she said it was high and it was
it was unfinished I'm just imagining her
like who's gonna be [ __ ] she was
saying that she was having guests come
over to her new house every new place
and that she didn't want them sitting on
her on the floor or on her bed who now
they won't be sitting you know in what
scenario is a tiny bench okay Mike who
was buying the tiny [ __ ] dog yes
she's probably surfing online she's like
how come everybody's not buy this doll
furniture [ __ ] so cheap this [ __ ] on
earth she thinks it's a brand yeah doll
dolls great doll Diaries or derice RVs
dough rice whatever that someone
commented in it like tweeted back and
said that's a really popular doll making
company she's like a
I mean he does say no three millimeters
everyone pointing out and she was like
everyone's getting upset at me for an
elegant at the dimensions like [ __ ] I
was it another dimension I think I'm the
authority here because I look the
closest to a creepy white person and I
don't even know that Branford Hall
closest yeah
closest very close very close very close
point but not quite there right guys
good impression okay yeah he does do a
chin strap sometimes oh yeah then people
started were playing with like girl I
know so they were like reply with their
own mom like they're thieves the same
thing happens to me last year she was
trying to get this rug and it was that
tiny like same sis like diuresis thieves
that dairies brand his [ __ ] mansion
though it should I just checked her
Twitter recently and then she ended up
posting this she's like man on my life
at this point it ain't mean I was wrong
for ordering that chair but bra like oh
god I ordered toilet seat cover and
these folks at me about a bonnet with a
hole in me isn't that supposed to go on
the lid and then the whole part is
supposed to go on the bottom of yeah yes
wait no because the bottom right there
isn't covered completely you see it
there's no solid on the inside they need
that for the guys back there there are
literally toilet seat covers like only
great ones yeah I grow like like nobody
has like a hundred percent shoot rate
when it comes to pool yeah you gotta be
like that's gonna be poop on that thing
nobody has the ball
have you ever seen have you ever seen
poop sweat all over the underside of the
toilet seat like someone put their thumb
over their [ __ ] and [ __ ] [ __ ] just
sprayed it out like when you put
not only not only that but like the
backside like on the front on the on the
top of the toilet like this part right
here like I've gone to my daughter's
room like what the father she takes [ __ ]
happens yeah what is it she's squatting
over her personal bathroom and how come
on that here in the artillery fire
exactly are you describing yeah and I'm
like oh you open the [ __ ] dam like
what is happening in here
my daughter is four then she put a hole
in the wall I had she had one of those
like standing racks for the toilet
tissue bike and I don't know how I feel
like she's picking up a swung gate she
put a hole in the [ __ ] wall you know
what she did she took a piece of paper
and taped it to the wall hide it I
respect it well she at least color at
the same color as the paper was the same
color but it was like it was like was a
piece of paper was a [ __ ] paper towel
she took with her paper towels like no
how did you find out I was too high
bathroom I like I like [ __ ] in her
bathrobe because it gets more natural
like my bathroom I also he doesn't have
a windows know what I'm sayin though you
call that's what you call a bathroom
bedroom you see that master bedroom
master bathroom but when it has a been
on the best for me that's an ensuite
like your office isn't ensuite yeah I
don't call it on suite but that's what
we call it with your bougie and everyone
Burbage I'm not bougie I've never heard
of that I'm definitely losing my driver
has a driver at the he finish driving me
I have somebody drive him home
easy water in my iron my dog only has
like purify water I'm super Bugaboo
nephew said Evian that him in Mooji
that's not bushi what you trash Fiji's
trash thank you for my iron is amazing
to put the Fiji in the iron is the
ultimate desert and here I thought you
were about your Busey I am super Busey
now I have luggage covers literally I
have come I have luggage and then I have
covers that go over my luggage to make
sure they make luggage covers where you
can put your [ __ ] face on it and I
want that so bad why would you put your
face on it black on black so but I'm
yeah very very very boozy no no no I tip
well just to let people know how well
I'm doing
books it was like so you got a small
coffee like it doesn't matter my face
yeah yeah remember we're talking about
again we're talking about the tiny Ben
oh my god sweet oh no I swap the natural
lighting look is better to [ __ ] in yes
it absolutely is it takes me forever to
order things because I have to go
through everything and I compare it to
another side I hate it yeah it was ayat
II and then I put it in my basket and I
wait a few days and see if I still want
it you do yeah yeah and then I go back
and bite if I wants you dude we shall
just leave why everything I have tried
to do that where I'm like trying to just
order it just like it's just [ __ ]
just order this thing you need this
[ __ ] thing so then I order it and
then it's not the thing that I need or
like it's somehow damaged or whatever it
doesn't fit cuz I didn't look at the
dimensions I never returned things easy
now because they have the coals drop off
you just [ __ ] go over there see and
they wrap it for you don't need to put
in a box they wrap before you that dude
helps me all the time to do the helping
all the time it's a JK fan service I'm
come in what's up man
I'm like look I'm not cheap all right
I'm not returning things you don't have
to give that you should blame me I need
him to know he's Jesus keeper bujji
image I mean
image says it no know when I'm in Jean
the first time she shook my hand I was
like Bob she was a Gina about cheap
people for something they already pulled
through like the guy that opens at the
door at the hotel I just give him a
hundred just like I'm not I'm not cheap
but I am lazy that's why my roots are
[ __ ] right now but there's nothing
I'm so lazy I don't get it died in the
first place you win [ __ ]
[Music]